it's always an expert courageous team of
men who disarmed these bombs and I got
to wondering what would happen if a team
of non-experts ever tried to disarm one
of these bombs oh ok cut off sync do you
sing to sync it up three two one sing ok
good all right good he's a here yes
right yeah ok see you dressed down we
have we have five minutes to deal with
three modules easy I don't even know
where to start you don't worry i'll
simply vitac you what to look for ok
Jesus all right your other frame now
Lucas dancing dance for you all right
look for a big button it has text fund
what paper you okay what kind of ah
it'll be very obvious okay on the
subject of the button and then there's
one with text yes okay the color the
button is ragams to the texting sex
dating what is red in the bus who saw
the Braille display press and
immediately release the button as if the
button is red in the button says hold
press and immediately release the button
alright says Danny hi mr. buddies yellow
that's Paris if there is more than one
battery on the bomb and the button says
detonate press and immediately release
the button alright next one is a wires
that go horizontally in the stacked on
top of each other and they go across oh
[ __ ] Oh Jonah remember horizontally not
[ __ ] vertical Jackie there's a
four-minute what you this is yours oh
thanks thanks cool oh yeah I in the
middle of someone like a door /
complicated wires okay risotto going up
and down okay not up and down Wow oh
wait oh [ __ ] ro ROG yeah it has no cable
is Spanish my name is mine Oh display
got to be work [ __ ] it let's do it these
ones are horizontal okay all right I
have six wires if there are no yellow
wires in the last digit of the serial
number is odd cut the third wire right
otherwise if there is exactly one yellow
dire okay last one is Simon Says well uh
see monkey thing oh [ __ ] see modistes
Simon Says acquitted be quiet pumpkin
hear us haha okay understudy exercise
and says okay all right I have no
strikes and there are no bowels in the
serial number
what is four colored buttons with
flashes back you said if the serial
number comes homes a vowel it doesn't
right no bowel okay uh no strikes blue
yellow green red it doesn't know i've
been squatching red and yellow goes by
me baby what Roger wash it it says no
strikes and then on the Left flash it
has blue okay what's yellow is actually
implements take me out lucky uh blue
flash hit yellow no wait yo flash right
all right wow it's not true no Carl you
hate and hit it again Kyle was wrong
you're in blue yeah that's like Jagger
told me to hit hain't blue what's it
blue then red what's the what's the
right watching blue it's [ __ ] red and
yellow ok what do i press it says shoot
like slow and then row I have two
strikes down ok two strikes already yes
yellow if you see yellow get red how
many words hi how many modules were in
the spill what is greenie
you have two strikes get blue Ryan
you're on crease now you are bad news
call 911 the volcano help stop the plane
right is the sweet safari or something
image oh okay who's next oh my god we
did it we did
okay look it's like one of those
infinite mirror elevators look as hi I
can see your undies with five wires Kyle
son Nolan hey we'll hey